joe manchin has become public enemy
number one for the left after announcing
he was a no vote on the build back
better plan as we just discussed now
manchin was attacked personally and the
state of west virginia universally
actress bette midler sometimes singer
went so far as to say mansion sold us
out this is a tweet he wants us all to
be just like his state west virginia
poor illiterate and strung out she later
apologized but i'm not accepting and
it's just not hollywood trashing the
mountain state as congressman jamal
bowman decided to make the this whole
issue about race
it's tremendously frustrating for me as
a black man in america because once
again it's an example of
joe manchin as a white man showing that
he doesn't care about black people he
doesn't care about latinos he doesn't
care about immigrants he doesn't care
about women and he doesn't care about
the poor
what
here to respond is the governor of that
great state a former democrat himself
getting ready to coach a great
basketball game high school basketball
team but stopping with us first
jim justice thanks so much for joining
us i want you to to answer those people
who decided to rip your senator and rip
your
state brian there's no call for it in
all honesty it's untol it's not
tolerated just period you know from the
standpoint of what senator manchin did
he stepped up he stepped up and echoed
the people of west virginia the people
of west virginia are hard working people
the people of west virginia know what
this country is all founded around it's
not founded around socialism it's not
founded by the promotion of something
that is so awry that it doesn't make one
bit of sense it's founded upon
americans not being average and with all
of that and everything through all the
decades of time america has risen to the
top have we not and we're not going to
slip back and joe manchin we are very
proud of his vote and everything to stop
this terrible terrible carnage that's
happening from washington but
nevertheless we hope joe stands tall and
from the standpoint of bette midler you
know all i would say is shame on her i
mean really and truly to call west
virginians illiterate and to say that
we're strung out and poor and when west
virginia is leading the way over and
over and over whether it be in in the in
the cova you know call or where whether
it be you know in leading the way
becoming a diamond in the rough that
everybody's missed we're pumping out
surplus after surplus in this state
beyond belief the lowest unemployment
rate in the history of our state
absolutely thing you know one thing
right after another whether it be
leading in tourism diversification on
and on and on and for bette midler to
say that it is just plain not tolerable
so governor you were on with us when you
decided i'm no longer going to be a
democrat i'm going to be a republican
and your state every year gets more and
more ready you're at 40 donald trump i
think won your state by 40 points
what's your message to joe manchin about
the party you're in now as opposed to
the party he's in now
well the party that he's in now and
nobody can understand i mean that's all
there is to it i mean if you look at
what's happening with president biden
look at look at what's going on at the
border what look what's going on in
afghanistan what happened in afghanistan
look what's going on with crime and look
at explosion the explosion of inflation
that's eating all of our lives right now
we just did a thing in west virginia the
other day where we're going to we're
going to try to pass another you know
unprecedented five percent pay raise to
all of our state employees teachers
everybody but not only that we're going
to do a two and a half percent and i'm
going to mispronounce this but inflate
in plato scene which is basically a
vaccine for inflation you know to be
able to give a one-time inflato scene to
our to all of our state employees so the
greenbrier east uh high school girls
basketball team uh you'll be coaching
them shortly you're in the locker room
right now you're at wynn 499 after
opening up the season
are those girls around you that you
could we could actually get a look at
this team who you're commanding i think
you're about six seven yourself
so do we see this team can you zoom in
they're absolutely here and we gotta get
ready to coach a game brian and uh you
know i love the kids and i really truly
believe with all in me that public
people should give back we ought to be
with these kids these kids are the
greatest or the greatest and uh and
before i go you know i i want i want
them to say hi to you and they walked in
here real shy they didn't make any noise
i mean for crying out loud they got to
get ready to play so brian i'm gonna go
we got to coach again thank you so much
all right go go good luck ladies i know
you got a big game tonight who's going
to doubt that they're going to go up 6-0
and get win number 500 for the governor
uh it's amazing how much he has on his
plate i went to brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now